[Music]
thirty miles north of philadelphia lies
the borough of newtown pennsylvania home
to this historic brick hotel
owner veranda qua a former therapist
bought the property in 2006 with her son
cj who serves as a silent partner in
their business
we bought the brick hotel because it was
an investment opportunity when we first
purchased the place we were told that it
was going to be of sort of a hands-off
it'll run itself you just have to watch
it of course
we had no idea
zero idea what this business is about
i always said to my son maybe this year
we'll make a profit maybe this year
we'll make a profit and it never
happened she used to be in family
therapy so patience comes with that job
and i've seen her have a short fuse
where she wouldn't do that
before we bought the place
when i came here it blew my mind away
that you're still putting in money so i
cut out a lot of stuff here and
it really
annoyed and irritated people and they
basically started the dislike verindar
plan
[Music]
it has been a bit of a dictatorship here
with verandah
you know it's either her way or not her
way no no no no no no no no no brendar
is a control freak she is involved in
everything she will not release or
relinquish
control ever here's the ball you want me
to put it in she's not a people person
she has no people skills
she just screams out demands and she's
very rude at times
french onion on here now there's such a
turnover with staff that i don't even
know their names in eight months i've
probably seen over
50 people go
some people come in for one shift and
they listen to her for five minutes and
they roll right out the door
i wish i had two clones of me
and believe me this place would be
harping
i feel that brook might have become like
the laughing stock of newtown
so the reputation around town is that
you know no nancy they call me the crazy
lady which is fine to me you know what
if i'm crazy because i'm trying to save
the business so be it
i think we're at that point where this
is really our last chance
if we don't figure something out it's
either sell it get rid of it because we
can't sustain it
[Music]
before i came to town i heard the brick
hotel had a high turnover rate so i had
my team reach out to former employees so
i can get some information before
checking in
uh
first of all good morning good morning
i've never met such a large team of
ex-employees uh
this is a small showing oh yeah what
there's more
hundreds
hundreds i would
um how much turnover is there with staff
when i left verindar had been through
almost 50 managers
15
50 50. 50 managers 50.
and the biggest problem with the place
is what verindar
she's been cruel to people i watched her
and she's
she's mean and she can be a bully and
i've seen her reduce people to tears
wow that's terrible
you know there's so much neglect between
not only the staff her managers but her
customers as well
seriously
i couldn't take it anymore i worked the
holiday season and it was kind of like
the last straw for me and what made you
quit i worked all of those parties
through the whole month of december i
was lucky to receive some payback like
in february with your tips yeah she'll
cut you a check in six weeks when she
feels like it she wouldn't let you go
pick up your paycheck she called the
cops on you
you said she called the cops on you oh
off time numerous times
but seriously call the police because
you wanted your money yes you're a
threat yeah seriously i mean it sounds
like a dictatorship as opposed to a boss
that's there to support
people loved it there it was very homey
the opposite of now all the locals came
we had a booming hotel business wow it
was such a great place and then the
quality just steadily went downhill and
i think she had a complete lack of
respect for the staff and didn't
understand that your staff is a huge
asset
what a mess can i ask you a question
please have you met her oh no at least i
just arrived seriously
this morning you are in for a treat
i was curious just by the way you were
speaking because i thought he hasn't met
her yet has he no no no so calling the
cops
you know
high staff turnover um standards
dropping i haven't got much confidence
however i'm gonna tackle it head-on
you don't look very optimistic do you
thank you
wish me luck
thank you take care
look at the size of this place
oh dear
what happened there
damn
when did that happen you know it's been
here since i've been here oh really hi
i'm mary ann this may seem thank you
likewise good to see you i get nervous
when checking the hotel the windows are
smashed
uh anyway how are you i'm good thank you
i'm happy to be here
are they bullet holes in the wall oh you
know they might very well be i'm not
sure what they are we're 250 years old
250 years old
uh what's wrong with the place i think
it's beautiful place but i think it
really just needs some
upgrading and uh which parts beautiful
help me
certainly not the entrance with the
smashed windows well i think
it could be beautiful yes it's been
neglected for a while
what happened here
oh
oh my
god
oh my gosh
that looks much better wow
dear idea
i don't know if render is not going to
be too happy
you just ripped the wallpaper down that
was fantastic
what time is the owner calling in she
might be here i can check i'd love to
meet her oh he's bringing verandah up
we're running door
hi
how are you good how are you very well a
little bit nervous the smashed glass
what happened there
it's been there since before i bought it
how long we had the hotel 10 years 10
years and you didn't think about
replacing it first impressions customers
walked through the door it's it's the
original have you been drinking
you look like a drink
did you run a hotel before you bought
this ten years ago yeah
never never no no what did you do
therapist for children
i did that for 20 years that was my
practice wow okay uh 201
i'll see you uh shortly i'm gonna go
check in and uh
unpack okay
place is filthy
[Music]
housekeeping please
that's mine
[Music]
oh jesus let me get housekeeping for you
housekeeping called fire brigade
oh no are you the housekeeper i'm not
i'm looking for i'm i'm caitlin okay
please me so my hands are dirty so i'm
just gonna shake hands
like that sure no when was last time
this place was cleaned there's dust and
[ __ ] everywhere uh talay is here every
day uh so i would assume
right cleaning i mean under here look
i'm not talking about a couple of weeks
of dust i'm talking years i'm behind
here as well look
hi
oh
geez how are you hi are you good yes i'm
fine fine right what do you do
housekeeping stop which house
this house come over
look at the mess down there what's that
let's get the place clean fabulous let's
just have a little test here
look at that
look at that do you have a program that
you clean floor by floor
a program
no no
uh where is my room to what
your room now what's that up there
who sits here
is it a [ __ ] tea party for rats or
stuart little in for dinner tonight what
the [ __ ] is that
oh what is it like pet corner
we drop our cats off for dinner here
jesus
man who does this
you care to join me come on
go forward
come on let's let's see it's a friend
let's talk about your cleaning habits
i can fit right there no no
my my butt's way bigger than yours so
take a seat
now we have some menus please oh sure
yeah absolutely so
what in the [ __ ] is going on
[Music]
i actually said something about that but
you know
you
comfy absolutely not no
all jokes apart forget the mice party
tea parties cheerleaders [ __ ] hang
out what is the biggest problems here
because i'm like this
the mold the
we got rid of the dust what do you mean
the mold where's the mold
oh
great yes take to the mold
okay
thank you
let's start this way but where
let's go this way
first
mold
i guess it starts i don't know exactly
where it comes but it comes from
somewhere on the shower curtains i
accidentally change it there is mold do
you tell the owner to change these out
yes sir and any response she'll get to
it oh look at this
look at that come over
is there more that is mold yes i said
that that's mold
seed
bloody how
when was all the linen last changed look
at the colour of this
how much sweat is on there oh man
oh
look at the color of that so that's what
that is sweat that's sweat
and then is that a is that a tube
television
how old
have you ever heard of a flat screen
yeah i got five
you've got five flat screens at my house
what a mess
what's that in there
what
a empty box of tights silk perfections
does the owner ever come into these
rooms
since i've been here i've probably seen
her here maybe once
once upon a time these were white right
you see these look at the color of them
how grey and dirty
god they stink oh you can tell this
balls have been white oh man i was
worried about your eyes for a second
there where's my room please
201 please tell me it's not worse than
this one
201
bloody hell
what a mess
dust everywhere and all this what is
this
terrible
girl how you doing found all
the nasty
no no i thought that the curtains were
gold
no
pharrell they were supposed to be white
oh my goodness i am apart
and then
just underneath it all
right now it's pretty obvious that
the owner
doesn't even put a cent
back into this room
beam into the hotel
but
when an owner can't be bothered to
change a smash window and reception
i don't hold much hope for the rest of
the hotel and look at that up there
what's that
check out time
11 a.m yeah i'll check out way before
that my love
[Music]
hi
nice to meet you i'm tammy gordon good
to see you good to meet you um and your
sales and event coordinator at the brick
rumors has it you do a lot of events do
a lot of events how many a week on
average about 350 a year it sounds like
this is the oxygen that's keeping this
place alive unfortunately that's the
truth wow what other problems are there
help me uh staffing is
terrible why are so many staff going
through the door what is it or randar is
firing them often i'll come in on monday
and see who didn't make it through the
weekend she's very tough to work for the
bottom line is the problem is the owner
yes there's nobody else here starts at
the top i appreciate your honesty well
we appreciate you being here
after learning the hotel's revenue is
strictly from events i want to see how
bad the food really is seasonal local
fresh
i ordered a couple of items the french
onion soup which was tasteless that's so
bad terrible
so i opted for something with a little
more flavor
that tastes better
then i ordered something i've never
heard of before a cauliflower steak
which by name i should have known better
that is a mess who put on the menu
and a crab sandwich which maybe i would
expect to be frozen
but not from a can product of china
fresh
mm-hmm
seriously are we done is there a did not
you've got your burger still do you know
what cancel it absolutely because if
it's coming from the same kitchen forget
it got it yeah tell the chef i travel
light and i haven't got that many
[ __ ] pairs of knickers thank you
oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm taking out
he's freaking out cancel everything else
no more
no more he said enough
[Music]
uh
take me to the kitchen introduce me to
the team
place is huge
kitchen is massive
uh so where's the chef
hello
i'm not the chef you're not the chef are
you done you are a chef though you've
got a jacket on yes sir that's how chefs
tend to dress yeah maceo nice to meet
you likewise good to meet you too and
this is very very sexy all right so you
got it you're the chef i'm not the chef
no you're the chef egg chef but not fish
aisha
there's two of them there's two of them
the other one's uh where's the head chef
well we have both of them in charge no
such thing your set of rules your set of
rules
doesn't benefit the customers i'll come
back to the food in a minute i'm in
shock
before i got here i met
a dozen
of your ex-employees okay i couldn't
believe the amount of staff that have
left this building in the last two years
why are you going through so many staff
i don't know you don't know i think i
hire people and uh oh so it's them
not good enough for you so yes
when you have a young member of staff
that
is owed money
and they won't leave the building until
you pay them and you call the police on
them what kind of business are you
running here
who said that are you saying now that
they're lying
please i don't know why are you saying
they're lying simple yes or no i cannot
tell people you cannot say it's
inaccurate though i do it's inaccurate
yes
i have
witnessed verndar call the cops on a
number of people she has
a close relationship with the newtown
police department
do you care about this hotel
it's not funny i mean i am not here to
laugh let's get that right
let's move on to my reception when i
walked in and there's dust and [ __ ]
everywhere when i say dust i'm talking
dust that's been embedded for years
and there's mold on the carpet
i'm a little bit lost to words i ever
sat down in the restaurant and had
dinner yeah right
top of your menu it's
fresh
seasonal
local it's canned food i'm not a chef
and i don't
know all these things
what's wrong you're feeling sick no i
need to take something out of the oven
so you take it out the oven what is this
tomorrow's chicken
i see you laugh
what is this
a game
you have to [ __ ] wake up
[Music]
hi hey guys how are you
excited yes we're checking in
no problem
bye bye
hi how are you hi how are you nice to
meet you first name is i'm jessica
jessica good to see you i heard you had
a great time today great time not but uh
yeah let's wait and see uh who's that
that is cj that is verandar's son
oh hi cj yes i'm one of the co-owners as
well good to me how many times were you
here i'm here right now probably less
than once a month even
i've got another job that i prefer full
time
uh manage i.t i see well why did you buy
this why did we buy this it was an
investment opportunity when we first got
into it we're told that it was turnkey
hands off so that was 10 years ago
yes have you seen any return on that yet
zero zero when do you think it's coming
[Music]
well
i have been talking about that quite a
bit over the last six months because
it's getting difficult to keep putting
money in wow
in your mind
forget him what's wrong with the place
i'm very sorry because i know this is
your mom but i can't
i can't deal with how she treats me it's
like when we don't need her here she's
here and she's on me about the smallest
things
wow
do you have one foot in their camp or
one foot in your mother's camp um
i'm split between the two i've actually
had employees tell me why aren't you
around more because you're pleasant to
deal with how's this gonna get turned
around if she's still micromanaging and
dictating to everybody about how this
place should be run
she says if she's not here it's things
will fall apart and it won't get done
that sounds right
i know he's customized hi guys how are
you good evening how are you welcome how
are you well you guys have a reservation
yeah weinstein
sorry about the smash window
and the crowd's from china
from china okay you guys can follow me
i don't go to china for crap
[Music]
gentlemen i have one order for you it's
just the first course on the first table
it's just two soup of the days
thank you
[Music]
okay who's next
[Music]
i got all the soups all right first
thing is this it's uh
apple pear no bleach blue cheese
and an eggplant stack
[Music]
where's the apple pear can we get this
out
why is she doing this is she always on
the hot plate she is she's never quiet
which ones are done can you guys take
those down is this done
no i've taken my stuff down that's done
yeah wow it's a little aggravament
guys waiting on the rack it's coming
verindor is coming we're working it hard
they're making us nervous oh my goodness
charlie carly
what i'm coming what is that put this
here take this this is yours
no that is my new york street this is
craziness
who's drawing the cauliflower
are you cooking the cauliflower now
yes
i know she
swear to god
can you flip this
and what should you do cooking i have no
idea did you normally cook yeah
this is crazy absolutely crazy
[Music]
what a mess
the wheels are stuck it was just sliding
on the [ __ ] grease
oh god
that is
gross miranda you got two seconds sure
just stand behind there will you oh my
goodness now please stand behind there
i'm
i'm
what is this
you guys just cleaned this is this from
today
i don't even know what's back there
verindar what
when was that cleaned it's they just
killed him two days ago they just
spilled everything there come here
i know
hand on heart that is not from yesterday
that is not from yesterday
what's that up there seriously what's
your eyes what's your eyes
who cleans this [ __ ]
who is it since i've been here no one's
cleaned it since you've been here no
one's clean i appreciate your honesty
brenda yeah
[Music]
since he's been here he's never cleaned
it
this place is disgusting
like this
well i'm a robot i don't come and do
this you don't want i trust them that
they would kill me together
you you guys cleaned the floor the other
day didn't you
we cleaned the line the other day we
sweeped the line you said you guys took
out i never said that i met him
you're just trying to make excuses
yes you are
aren't you embarrassed
very
at least you taught the [ __ ] truth
the owner's in denial
that has been pulled out for [ __ ]
months i wasn't bored out
what a [ __ ] mess
what is this
bloody hell
holy crap
oh my god what in the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
oh my gosh what in the [ __ ] is that
that's grease from the hood can you stop
lying
that was not cleaned yesterday i'm
telling you this is greased from the
hood but they haven't cleaned them do
you have any idea what happened if that
caught fire
why not now do you have any idea if that
caught fire
i do
what are you doing
you stop caring
no that's not true i mean that's the
sign of an owner that cares
i want an answer
i'm going upstairs by the time i come
down i want an answer
cj is he on i don't know where he went
jesus
oh my god
right
i'm unconvinced that this place is clean
so
i want to run a quick bacteria test
it looks disgusting
i don't think these vents have been
cleaned for years
time to tell
did you talk to ramsay
no he came down here looking for you
there she goes
now 10 to 20 is deemed as sort of clean
respectable anything over 30 is
unhygienic
dangerous and this is reading
573.
come in you were looking for me uh sit
down what is that this is a very simple
hygiene test
anything above 30 is in the danger zone
okay
573 from the air conditioning unit
i don't have an answer for that sorry
that's
cj
573.
let's do another one how long's this
chair been here but i believe since we
bought the place have you seen the
stains on it
see the stains there yeah
let's see what that says
did you ever stay here uh no i've never
stayed here you've never stayed here in
10 years no wow so you bought a hotel
you invested in it with mum and you've
never stayed here
i'm amazed
446.
and you've got no idea it's like this
what's the bathrooms like oh my god
[Music]
do you know the shower curtains got mold
on them no i did not your housekeeper
pointed it out
those hairs there
at this rate i really should be wearing
gloves
oh dear
a shower cut
[Music]
what
5
680
what in the [ __ ]
seriously
i
i don't have an answer for that at all
5
hundred and eighty
that is the volume of live bacteria
i'm gonna wash my hands [ __ ] it now
five thousand
what in the hell is going on
i'm gonna go and just check
301
sorry disturbing are you well i'm so
sorry do you mind this we've got some
issues downstairs and found some pretty
horrific stuff i know you get ready for
bed i'm sorry that's okay
i honestly didn't think they're gonna
put anyone in here today
[ __ ] i'm right look i'm sorry
that's mold underneath
no you did not did no you did not really
that is disgusting and i did a bacteria
test i've been doing them all day on my
shower curtain was mold
i just took a shower oh [ __ ]
we just give me two minutes okay oh my
god
let's go come on let's go oh no oh my
god leave your bags there make your way
down to the front please leave the phone
it's not important customers are way
more important
lead the phone
customers out
customers out
let's go out barry drop what you're
doing go off the premise please we're
not going to be serving this anyway
quick let's go we've got to move fast on
that let's go everybody's standing in
front just wait two seconds is everyone
out this isn't the drill
first of all i just want to apologize
there's no fire
more importantly over the last three
hours all i've done is a bacteria test
i want to apologize to all of you but i
want to stop right now while i try
endlessly to get through the owner who's
totally oblivious
this is the owner we all ate here we
were all playing on st here and you're
smiling like a smirk on your face
what i'm not gonna do is just allow this
lady to laugh at me you guys to pay good
money and eat
and i'm certainly not letting paying
guests stay to sleep here i'm done my
team will assist you getting yourself
out of there relax there is no fire but
we are not going to continue i want to
stop right now and shut this place down
oh my god
i am so sorry
i need you now
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
when are you going to get real
when are you going to stop close the
[ __ ] door and take a good look at
yourself in the mirror if i say anything
it's not believed so what's the point
what do you mean it's not believed what
is wrong with you what i can what is
wrong with you
what is wrong with you
there's nothing wrong with me it's just
after 10 years i'm here every single day
they don't like me and they insult me
and they disrespect me every second they
work here they steal from me they're on
their cell phones for four hours a day
you're disrespecting every member of
staff you're blaming everybody for what
you've created somewhere you switched
off and ignored all the problems and
took it out on the staff
that's what they're telling you yes
that's what they're telling me
right now
i'm going to tell you something you've
never heard before
you're out your depth
[Music]
last night after shutting down the hotel
and seeing verandah had no communication
with employees i organized a staff
meeting
anyone down there
but verandah was nowhere to be found
there you are they've been looking for
you
they said that you'd ran away no i'm not
running away
you don't want to be in front of the
staff why not
my biggest problem is that you
have shut down
and you refuse to let anybody in i walk
through the way those people steal from
me every single day and so you had some
incidents with some bad stuff years ago
and then you think everybody that comes
through your door is it
it's exactly the same no they're not
it's not about a one-on-one anymore you
can't just focus on one individual and
you've done that brilliantly
in the previous career
running a team managing a hotel is
completely different
we need to get the team back on side and
they need to believe in you and you need
to believe in them
it's a two-way thing well it's a process
too
it is a process
but if you don't walk back through those
doors and face the music
with me
then i'm gonna go as well because i
can't do this without you
i i don't know how let me show you how
[Music]
uh well first of all
thanks for coming in early this morning
um listen this is hard
there seems to be a massive conflict
how do we get the trust back in the room
what would you like to see change
we just did a funeral last week 90
people and there was two servers zero
buses zero bartender well of course it's
a money issue it's a budget issue so i
took it over and that is why we we had a
schedule on monday for the cooks
we come back tuesday the schedule's
completely changed do you do the
schedule
but this should be the chef's job
you need to be responsible for your own
departments i'm like macy's responsible
for the kitchen tammy is responsible for
the events you have to offload the work
from you and give them the
responsibility i yes that's a mistake
when was last time you had a meeting we
had a service staff meeting in here that
we get yelled at and it just gets
hostile and people get up and me include
it and walk out and
it just doesn't
help anything let's stop there we're not
going to this is why this is why no one
wants to no one ever if you want a
manager
wait a minute but you must understand
now that's the wrong way to handle
things
seems to be a really bad vibe in the
room that we can't shake off
but if you want to clear the air people
need to turn their phones off when they
walk in and clock in
can i say something about the phone i
have said that million times please do
not bring your cell phones in here and
invariably i come in at two o'clock i
see you guys outside on your cell phones
that is a break cell phone it's never
seen me on my cell phone
okay fine i mean you know maybe you're
not doing it but other people are doing
it
why is there
so much distrust in this building
it's
people
stealing from me
drinking on the job doing shots over
here that's not now
we're talking as if it's present yes but
there is i mean you know these guys
aren't taking shots
but what i'm trying to say you're you're
accusing them of somebody else's bad
practices
what you need to stop doing
is blaming them for the past
can you trust your team
yes
tell them that okay i'll try please i
can't i can promise wow i can only try
look at that smile that will go a long
way
we all know it's not gonna change
overnight it's a process
so we need to embrace that process and
we need to install confidence
i'm open to the change that he wants me
to
follow
if that's what's going to make this
place a success
i feel like the staff meeting was a step
in the right direction
vrandar seems to be coming around but i
want to make sure she is 100 committed
morning uh thanks so much for coming i
really need to talk to cj privately
because he's the one person who can help
get through to her
uh
cj i'm gonna be honest i'm gonna be up
front i'm not dealing with a
hotelier i'm dealing with your mum
and i'm sure she holds a special place
in your heart but
unfortunately she's running around like
a dictator and she's not letting any of
the staff breathe she's stifling the
business i've had conversations with her
about a few things similarly i've told
her
um the way we were brought up and raised
in india that tone in conversation
doesn't work here and uh she struggled
to be very honest adapting to that part
of it um you adapted brilliantly come to
this country but she's one tough cookie
you know that yeah she is nitpicking the
staff and then she's not giving any of
them responsibility she needs to be less
hands-on okay and more supportive no i
know i know
this is crazy mid-60s she shouldn't be
running around like this no she was very
honest with me last week she told me i
want to spend more time with the kids
and my time is running out and i haven't
heard her say that
ever right but she needs to let go okay
so how can i help i need a commitment
from you got to be there to support her
we need to get rid of that stubbornness
from your mum and make her understand
that this business can be fruitful she
just has to step back okay we can't
continue like this is do or die and we
need to step up okay all right i'm gonna
have a talk with her today please
we got one more shot at this
after spending time with cj he clearly
sees the issues his mother has and i
have asked him to reinforce the changes
she needs to make what we should talk
about is how do you let go
the responsibility is shifting
which means you don't run around doing
things
if it's maceo's kitchen if you're making
that decision it's not your problem to
deal with let jammy and the kitchen chef
do everything
i had learned it the hard way at my job
i was working 70 hours a week mother
yeah
but when i got the team in place and i
stepped away
i only get involved when there's an
escalation okay
sorry i mean you know i can do that and
you know what let's see what happens
with veranda on the right track the next
order of business is starting the
renovation process
the brick hotel needed drastic changes
so my team worked through the night to
get the hotel ready for relaunch welcome
to the new brick inn
wow
oh my god
wow
wow
oh my goodness it's amazing
[Applause]
would you like to come up and see my
room yes yes
[Music]
wow
oh my god
wow oh my gosh i'm about to take a dab
i'm taking the dad i think i might have
to come check it out
i don't know
everything
about these rooms are amazing wow
i'm excited to come
to work and clean go in front of jump on
them go ahead come on jump down oh my
gosh and you'll do it afterwards
oh my goodness very nice
thank you so much
after updating the brick hotel with a
modern look
i give them a classic menu that is
perfect for the town
and can better accommodate catering for
the large-scale events that take place
at the hotel
hi good evening welcome to the brick
hotel as for the relaunch i invited the
locals not only to dine at the brig how
are the first couple bites of everything
oh fantastic they're the best i've ever
actually had in my life but to tour the
renovated rooms as well
oh
mike look at this
oh my god look how nice this is
ah while on the hotel side everything
has been well received the kitchen is
running smoother than ever meatballs
aren't cheating sprouts cherries yes one
at a time six muscle spots yeah
eighty-six brussels sprouts please
really think that's a good sign thank
you and with cj having a presence
brussels
no what sprouts
you mean go get them he's able to
prevent his mother from slipping back
into her old habits it's okay
you said it's a good sign
now she can focus on her duties as an
owner
happy yes yes first of all it's so nice
to see you smile yes she had to walk
around this town with your head up high
well i apologize for
the difficulty i gave you initially okay
and anything i want to see you do is
from time to time come in here and walk
around like you did all night tonight
with charm and grace
i've told them that you are banned from
behind that line
okay okay all right i promise you all
this stuff will happen
promise me yes
i'm not a person who expresses
joy or you know you know jumping up and
down and things like that
but it's really really wonderful it's
given us
a lot of oxygen for a second life best
wishes take care thank you
wow what a week
[Music]
after leaving the brick the reputation
of the hotel was on the mend
cj became a more visible owner and
verandah stayed true to her word in
trusting her staff to do their jobs and
her employee turnover is at an all-time
low
with these changes in place the brick is
well on its way to being what it once
was